let's start with what's going on here
right now because we're in a massive
correction it's not even massive but
it's a big correction let's just
call it what it is it's a correction
the whole like
markets go sideways they go up they go
down they go left they go right that's
what they do volatility is good it's
like listen
people that freak out and get pissed off
about the crypto markets oh i lost the
bag or
usually it's for one of two reasons the
first reason is they don't have a long
enough timeline meaning
they're focused in the very short term
they're hoping to like
10 000 x a 2 000 investment in some [ __ ]
coin that's in like the top
like 19 000 or something like that
and it was a terrible investment it went
nowhere and they lost everything on
something they rolled the dice on they
were they thought was going to make a
huge amount of money
and
the other part of it too is a lot of
guys they'll buy bitcoin or ethereum or
you know something in the top ten but
then they'll go and swap it out or
they'll trade it for some other [ __ ]
coin or they don't have a long enough
timeline realistically
first tip for you biggest tip that i
would give you and it's one that i
adopted
probably in the last couple years i mean
i've been playing around with
cryptocurrency since 2017. i think i
even have videos on the channel
from way back in the day too
uh just talking about random [ __ ] that i
was tripping across when it became
interesting for me but
if you're not invested over
let's say a
four a four to ten year timeline it
should be at least four years right if
you're not getting into crypto for the
long haul
you're in the wrong spot honestly dude
like you're you're probably going to get
wrecked you're probably going to lose
the farm you know you're going to put it
in some stupid [ __ ] that you saw
on
a youtube video or or a friend told you
about or some rando you know across the
street's talking about it to some other
rando who's done nothing with her life
and they recommend some [ __ ] coin and
then you go and pile it all in because
some some stranger says oh you know this
is a uh this is a little known secret
and i have insider information or
something like that these guys get
wrecked all the time
so the first tip that i would want to
dispense on you guys is think longer
term
definitely think longer term way longer
term those of you that are trying to buy
in and out in four months or six months
or 12 months or a year and a half or two
years yeah
my opinion don't and i'm gonna tell you
what i do which works and makes me money
so that's the first thing second thing
is
what do we got here on the crypto
markets today we have
i just use coin market cap i know other
people like other um platforms but
currently they've got 19
419 cryptocurrencies listed
you think that you're going to roll the
dice in anything that's out of the top
10 and win
really
you have a crystal ball you can lead
into the future and see what's going on
because the vast majority and when i say
the vast i'm talking like 99.99
of all of those coins are not going to
be around probably in five to ten years
in fact
it'd be an interesting experiment i'm
sure somebody's done this at some point
if they went back to
pre-2017 levels and checked the list and
i think back then there was something
like nine or ten thousand so about half
the amount of coins today
probably the vast majority of those have
gone to nothing or disappeared okay so
the vast majorities are going to
disappear
the reason that i only play in the top
10 is because of that i've learned my
lesson
i've i've put vast amounts of money in
[ __ ] coins and for the most part i i
lose it okay it doesn't go anywhere
you get pissed off you feel let down
somebody lie to you they're it's it's
mostly because pump and dumps right and
that's one of the things you got to be
careful with with you know like the
youtubes today is there's a lot of guys
that run channels that have vested
interest in cryptocurrencies that they
then push on their audience or you know
their pdf or their road or the course or
whatever
a shitload of people buy it that pumps
up the price of it
and then they get out and they take
profits and then you guys are left
holding your you know with nothing
so
my next piece of advice is stay in the
top ten do not do not mess around with
anything outside of that
if you want to go into the top hundred
if you know you've got something going
on that you know about
it's well researched
but generally speaking my advice to
newer guys to stay in the top 10. you
really can't go wrong if you buy and
hold bitcoin or ethereum over 5 or 10
years
i think the chances of you
doubling tripling or quadrupling your
money are
much much higher
significantly higher in fact than you
finding some [ __ ] coin in the top 19 000
that you're gonna put a few grand in
that's going to turn into two million
um
chances of happening are very slim i'm
just being honest i've i've played those
odds i've looked at the odds the odds
are even worse today than what they were
in 2017 when we had half the coins on
the list and you had half to choose from
but the proven winner is still bitcoin
that's where all
that's where all the institutional money
goes that's where michael saylor puts
all of his money that's where
all the big guys are parking it that's
where the etfs come from the pension
funds
um
australia just launched a thing in etf
today canada's had several them for
quite a few years now that have been
licensed and regulated
qbtc i think is um the one that i've had
for a while and it's cool because i mean
like you've got a you know you've got an
rrsp or some kind of retirement plan you
just throw some money into it
it's uh it goes up when bitcoin goes up
it goes down when bitcoin goes down i
don't need that money probably for 15 or
20 years so i don't really give a [ __ ]
what happens in the short term and
neither should you to be honest with you
um you need to think longer term
everybody that's that's so pissed off
today about the markets oh it's red it's
a bloodbath
it's because you're not thinking long
term
um you know if you zoom out on where's
the bitcoin chart here let me throw it
up on the screen
share share share
[Music]
uh window and boom
if you zoom out and where are we at
right now this is uh one day
what a beauty
what a beauty i've been buying all all
across here and i'm going to show you
how i use b2x loans to double my bitcoin
for practically free towards the end of
the show so stay tuned for that
so let's let's zoom out let's go all
okay you know like i bought bitcoin
all the way up on 2017. i also bought it
here in 2017 as well
and i sold some bitcoin up around 20 um
you know like up over here on the way up
again
you know had i held on to it i would
have been far better off like it's it's
still
it's still at it it would have still
shown a profit on my balance sheet had i
had i held that
basically it's a long you know it's a
long hold thing right you know everybody
thought that you know bubbles were gonna
burst it was gonna go to zero when it
was at uh i think 17 19 000 194 i don't
know whatever it was it was like 20 000
just over 20 000 canadian
everybody thought it was all gonna go
down and disappear and they panicked and
the market collapsed and it went down to
3000 and change and i bought a whole
bunch down over here and here as well
too
but
if you just buy it and hold it long term
because you don't need it ideally for 5
10 15 20 years
there's only 21 000 or sorry 21 million
of these things they're never gonna make
any more of them they can't make any
more of them it's impossible okay it's
it's it's in the code right there's a
lot of people that come up with reasons
why it's gonna fail or gold is better
silver is better or this stocks better
that stocks better good go buy them i
don't give a [ __ ] you know buy buy
whatever you think works for you i'm
just i'm just sharing with you guys what
i've seen and what and what works for me
and i've got at least 50 or 60 percent
um of my money in cryptocurrencies and
that's mostly bitcoin and ethereum
so i'm just telling you what i do
straight up all right i mean you know
whether you're bought here here here or
here or here or here it doesn't matter
this this chart's going to keep going up
over time
it's a proven
strong asset class that outperforms
every other asset class out there and
has done so for years now so i don't
care don't listen to me what do i know
right i'm just showing you what i see
i just point to the facts you may not
like them it doesn't matter to me hey
guys i really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you